okay here's a question
various questions about chat GPT that
still seems to be in the news we're
still doing things with it it's
um uh you know the the big story there
tends to be that chat GPT is very good
at writing stuff
and the stuff might be fact it might be
fiction
um the uh the there's a the sort of
great thing that can happen of chat
asking well from alpha you know
questions which Wolfram Alpha can then
really factually respond to and that
becomes an interesting way to kind of
fact uh fact enhance what GPT might
otherwise be writing about that
otherwise might be complete nonsense
but there's a question here how does
chat GPT work
all right I can I can tell you something
about that
so first of all what is chat GPT it's a
well these days it's kind of a website
made by a outfit called open AI
um
that uh you can type text into and you
can have a conversation you can chat
with it you can ask it um uh questions
you can
ask it to write essays for you and it
does a remarkably good job of writing
very human sounding essays I think one
of the first tests I did on it was write
a persuasive essay I said uh for why
wolves are The Bluest kinds of animals
I'm not sure what I was thinking of
typing that in but the result was quite
interesting because it wrote something
that started off by saying people don't
usually think wolves are blue but in
fact there is a species of wolf that
lives in the Tibetan Plateau that is
blue and its name is this and it it's
it's blueness comes from the um uh the
same mechanism that leads to Butterfly
Wings being different colors and so on
and it went on and on and on from a
bunch of paragraphs and it's been kind
of taught to make essays like like some
high school kids are taught to make them
where there's a paragraph at the end
that says in conclusion comma
Etc et cetera Etc well
it's the things it wrote sounded really
quite convincing they were convincing
enough that I was kind of looking up on
the web is it is it actually true is
there is there in fact a blue kind of
wolf it was all complete nonsense but it
sounded very convincing and it had all
the right structure to be an essay about
blue wolves and so on
how does it work well
what what fundamentally it's doing is
it's making plausible English text and
what it's doing is you give it a prompt
a piece of initial text and it's trying
to continue that text in a plausible way
so if you say something like um uh well
in a very minimal level if it was doing
that character by character in English
if you put a cue you know it's followed
by you if you put a th well there's a
good chance it's followed by an e
at a level of letters we know the
statistics the chances that different
letters follow each other in in
something like English but now we can
generalize that we can make it bigger I
was just looking if you look at um nouns
and adjectives for example uh oh gosh I
was just doing this and I'm already
forgetting the results
um but you can um uh you can say things
like if you look at typical English uh
you know you could say AI is okay that's
a you know uh and then what's the word
that comes next you know maybe the next
word is most commonly very or uh you
know or or might just be you know an for
an interesting technology or something
like this but you can ask the question
what is the typical word that follows AI
is blah and so how do you define typical
well you know there are many words in
principle in the grammar of English that
could follow but there are particular
words that we humans have typically used
when we actually write essays and write
text about things and so for example in
the case of chat GPT it took a a crawl
of the web so the web has I don't know
how many it is these days it's a few
tens of billions of pages that are
reasonably human written that exist on
the web not not that many billions
um and uh there are many more if you say
how many different possible URLs are
there there are trillions of URLs that
get used but the number of really human
written I've got a lump of text some
human wrote this the number of pages is
is not that different from the number of
humans
um not that we were all writing one page
some of us have written a lot of pages
and other people haven't been in the
business of writing web pages but it's
you know tens of billions of pages is
that exist on the web and one of the
things you can crawl the web you just
start from one page and you follow all
the links on that page you follow all
the links from that page and chances are
you'll eventually get to sort of all the
pages on the web that's a good guess at
least and so for example there's a thing
called common crawl which is a project
where people have just collected have
gone and done that crawling and have you
know visited all these websites and and
repeatedly do so you can get that it's a
big big lump of stuff you can download
it from uh from various websites
um and that's that is a a copy of the
text content of the web it's a little
bit more complicated than that because a
typical modern website doesn't just have
text on it it has a bunch of JavaScript
and so on on it so you typically I think
you typically download things or walk
files which are some kind of web archive
formats and it all has to be unpacked
and you have to decide what you really
mean by the text and so on but let's
assume you've got big blobs of texts
that came from the web so you've got
that you've also got books there are
maybe some number of tens of millions of
books that have been written there are
um there are maybe five million books
that have been uh scanned maybe maybe a
little bit more than that now
um and you can scan the books you can do
optical character recognition you can
pick out the actual text and them so
that's another big Corpus material that
you can feed in and chat GPT was trained
on common crawl plus a bunch of books
and so when it says what word typically
follows this it knows that based on
having seen all of those different parts
of you know the web and these books and
so on it's like in those things and
those things that humans wrote what is
the typical thing that is the next word
okay so that's where it kind of starts
but this whole question about kind of
what is a typical piece of English it's
more than just saying give given that I
had the word is or the word you know I'm
going to have the word cat what's the
word that comes before cat might it be
black or white
um you know it's more than just word by
word kind of statistics of what's uh
what's happening more than just the
chance of what word follows which are
the word it's dealing with things on a
larger scale where it's saying when we
look at this whole flow of this sentence
or many sentences together
um what what is the typical way that we
would put these things together to to
form something which is sort of typical
of what you would see out there on the
web and so on and in fact in track GPT I
think in its current form it's really
dealing with things that are length well
2048 tokens a token is roughly a word
but sometimes there's more than one
token per word but that's the kind of
block that it's trying to say I'm trying
to make these things of this length that
are typical of what is sort of seen out
there in on on the web and by the time
you've given a prompt the the things
that can follow given that you say I
want to do this and this and this the
things that can follow are things that
are determined in many respects by The
Prompt that you gave so that's kind of
the big picture of what what it's trying
to do it's trying to mimic the sort of
typical stuff that it's seen that humans
have written out there on the web and in
books and so on and it is completely
remarkable as far as I'm concerned that
anything like that is as good at
producing sort of interesting essay type
text or poetry or whatever else as it is
it's remarkable it's something that I
think we is really a big clue in terms
of the way that we should think about
processes about human thinking and the
nature of meaning and text and and all
this kind of thing nobody knew that this
was going to work this well and in fact
sort of the precursors to modern chat
gbt didn't work as nearly this well
now there are there are lots of things
so so in terms of how does it actually
work that that's the big picture of what
it's trying to do mechanically how does
it do that I can tell you something
about that but uh just to talk a little
bit more about sort of the construction
of what's going on when we make an
English sentence we are partly we do it
according to the grammatical rules that
exist in English like we might say uh
you know
um
the uh what's a good example my gosh
the uh the crocodile ate the what do
crocodiles eat
the fish
um and uh the um
and then
you know that has a as a structure of an
English sentence the crocodile that's a
noun phrase eight that's a verb the fish
that's another noun phrase
um and so we know that English is set up
grammatically in as something that says
that that has the form of things like
noun a subject noun followed by a verb
followed by an object noun and so on
that is the grammatical structure now of
course we can have sentences that mean
absolutely nothing we say
um the moon you know
fished the elephant or something
it doesn't mean anything what does that
mean it's so we can have even more
meaningless sentences we can say uh
uh I don't know the we can say things
which are which where the where the
categories of thing that we put together
don't really fit in addition to things
that don't make sense because they're
not sort of physically possible they're
also things where the category of thing
isn't really right you could say
something like uh you know the house
eight
the lettuce
well houses don't eat things and it's
sort of or you could say the um
uh
you know the chair was happy
chairs don't have feelings so far as We
Know
um it's uh there there are all these
ways that sentences can be grammatically
correct in terms of their syntax in
terms of you know the parts of speech
and so on but they're not semantically
correct they don't have meanings that we
can immediately identify now you know in
if you're writing a poem it's a little
different a chair could be happy and a
poem because poems are a more elaborate
kind of more abstracted form of
communication than ordinary text but
this question of what fits semantically
together is an interesting question that
we really know very little about and
chat GPT is kind of showing us that
there is probably a way of thinking
about sort of what fits semantically
together just like there's a way of
thinking about what fits syntactically
together with parts of speech and nouns
and verbs and and grammars and so on and
and so that there's you know I think
it's a it's a kind of a very intro
interesting kind of wake-up call for the
analysis of kind of how meanings get
constructed and how how that works it's
interesting that you know I've been
interested in this stuff for a long time
and I I've actually been sort of shocked
recently I I you know what's been
studied about this and I I've certainly
known things that have been studied in
in the last few hundred years and I kind
of recently realized that most of what's
talked about actually goes back to
Aristotle from more than two thousand
years ago talking about kind of the way
that you construct things with meaning
and he had a very sort of primitive way
of thinking about that he also had a
very different view of kind of how the
world is put together and how one can
talk about things using science and so
on and it's time for a rewrite a reboot
of that and that's a project I'm I'm
hoping to do fairly soon
um but in any case let's come back to
the mechanics of how track GPT works
okay so it's it's got text as a prompt
it's trying to continue that text in a
statistically reasonable way okay how
does it actually do that
well
the uh the thing it's doing is it's
training a neural network
to uh to figure out how to do that let
me explain how that roughly works
so a neural net is kind of modeled on
the theory that we've had for the last
well kind of 100 years or so about how
brains work that brains have these
neurons and neurons can be either like
uh that they they can be you know active
or not active electrically doing
something or not doing something every
millisecond every every thousand
thousand times a second roughly neurons
are like oh am I am I am I going to fire
and generate an electrical impulse or
not and a typical neuron might have a
thousand connections to other neurons
that'll little dendrites little little
uh tentacles that sort of stick out in
these nerve cells and in our brains we
have maybe 100 billion nerve cells in
human brains
um and uh each one might have a thousand
connections to other nerve cells and so
the the idea is that when we think
what's happening is that there is
electrical activity one nerve cell it's
kind of spreading its activity to other
nerve cells spreading to other ones and
that's producing this kind of whole
pattern of electrical activity in our
brains that corresponds to our process
of thinking and we think that memory has
to do with the way that there are the
connections between nerve cells the
synapses the connections between the the
the the the den the the things that
stick out of the bodies of the nerve
cells the ways that those can be uh
whether those connections exist whether
they don't exist whether they're strong
connections whether weak connections we
think that memory and learning has to do
with the making of those connections
there are different ideas and detail
about how those connections get
strengthened and made and what produces
that that process of learning and
roughly you know we we have sort of a
short-term memory that works for a few
minutes and then gradually over the
course of a day or so will form a
long-term memory and there's there's
actual protein synthesis that happens
and so on there
um there's even you know very recent
theories about how there are kind of
dark synapses that have been kind of
lying around waiting to be activated
um and uh and then sort of come up come
come to be active when we when we form
memories and so on there's there's some
uncertainty about how that all works but
roughly the idea is that all these all
these nerve cells all these neurons they
have lots of connections to lots of
other nerve cells and there's something
to do with the the weights of the
connections that encodes the memories
and when we think when we use our brains
what's happening is that neurons
activity from one neuron is spreading to
others through these kind of connections
through these synapses and so on and so
artificial neural Nets are modeled on
the same kind of idea except then
instead of being actual nerve cells
there's just uh things in computer
memory um where it's uh we just have or
in woven language it's just a uh just
some piece of some some uh expression in
more from language that represents
um every uh sort of every one of these
nerve cells and represents sort of the
value of that nerve cell and then there
are weights by which this nerve cell is
kind of how much effect does one nerve
cell have on another nerve cell so you
end up with these um
uh with these big I mean mathematically
it's matrices or tensors which say I've
got this whole Vector of values this
whole sequence of values and I'm going
to determine from that a new sequence of
values and roughly what ends up
happening is you add up you say this is
the input sequence of values I'm going
to take some sum I'm going to weight
those values in different ways I'm going
to add them all up and then there's kind
of a thing where in addition to just
adding the numbers up you have some kind
of threshold the most common thing
that's done in current neural Nets I
think or relu which is actually a very
simple thing it's just if the the
weights where you add up all these
numbers can be either positive or
negative if it's if the resulting added
up thing is negative it's zero otherwise
it's just the value that you got that's
a simple way to to do this sort of
thresholding effect
um in in actual brains it probably works
a bit differently but that's kind of the
basic idea so the way it works is in an
artificial neural lesson probably in an
actual neural net in our brains they're
the succession of layers and you're kind
of you're saying oh we we give this
collection of activity to the first
layer then it does this transformation
it produces a collection of activity for
the next layer keeps on going layer by
layer up through the through the system
and eventually gets to the output
now
a question is uh and okay and so then
the issue is well okay what should all
those weights be that go from the input
to the output and so then you want to
construct different kinds of functions
that you can compute so for example one
thing might be on the first layer you're
giving a bunch of values that correspond
to pixel values from an image and what
you want is it goes through the network
many layers you know
50 layers or something and out at the
end you should have something where in
the output there's two thousand
possibilities
um that correspond to sort of a thing
with two thousand possible values and
one of those values let's say is going
to be big and most of the other going to
be small the big and those two thousand
things you should say they correspond to
two thousand kinds of objects that might
exist in the world cats and dogs and
elephants and chairs and tables and so
on each one of those things corresponds
to one of those objects and what you
want is a is a process where you give a
bunch of pixels in you go through 50
layers and then at the end the last
layer has as output something where most
of the values are close to zero except
there's a high value for a few things
and it's like okay that corresponds to a
picture of a cat
so what you're trying to do is you're
trying to in that particular case for a
neuron that's trying to identify images
what you're trying to do is say it
starts off with a bunch of pixel values
red green blue is this for this pixel
you know 10 million pixel values or a
million pixel values or whatever for an
image and then it's like go through
these 50 layers going through all of
these things where you've got all these
weights and so on you might have 10
million weights or something you know in
different arranged between these
different layers and eventually out at
the other end you're going to get
something where you have a sequence of
values and where they're mostly zero
except for the ones that correspond to
the things that it thought it saw okay
so the big question now is how do you
set up all those weights so that the
neural net actually behaves this way
and so that is where you have to train
the neural net how do you train the
neural net well you might start up by
just having completely random weights
and then you feed in an image of a cat
and it says oh that's half elephant and
half turtle or something and it's like
oh that's not right
okay how do you improve it well
you say that's not right that's pretty
far away from what is right there's a
what's usually called a loss function
it's like how far away from being right
are you and what you try to do is you
say okay you're pretty far away from
being right but if you just change those
values in this direction you'd be
getting closer to being right
and so then what you have to do is say
this is what we know in the output
you've got an elephant and a turtle but
you really just wanted it to be a cat so
that means the elephant and turtle
values are big but you really wanted the
cat value to be big so you can think
about that as the numbers for elephant
and turtles should be get smaller the
numbers for cat should get bigger that
provides you kind of a way to say these
are the these are the way I should
change the numbers in the output
so now the question is well how do you
change the weights and the inside of the
neural net to uh to get you closer to
the numbers that you want in the output
okay so this is a giant application of
calculus
um and it's it's sort of interesting
because there are many things in the
world where sort of calculus uh became
less and less useful and and gave way to
a lot of things that were much more
about programs and so on this is one
place where Calculus is still really
useful because what happens is you're
you're making use of well maybe I don't
want to go into the technical details of
this but it's in the end it's making use
of the chain rule in calculus operating
on you know in calculus you might study
a function of you know one variable two
variables three variables in neural Nets
we're dealing with functions of millions
of variables
um and what you're trying to do is
you're trying to say okay you want to
back propagate you want to propagate
backwards from from the way you want to
change the output what do you want to do
to these weights in the middle so that
if you were fed that input again you'll
be closer to getting the output you want
so what happens is you bash these neural
Nets really hard you do you know
trillion times you do this process of
saying hey what does this input give us
output
um and oh that's not quite right it has
you need to push it in this Direction
Let's propagate back from how we needed
to push it let's get these weights
changed in the middle and you keep doing
that you do it over and over and over
again and eventually the thing learns in
the sense that the weights that are
arranged in the middle actually do do
the thing you want so the most common
form of training well in in this setup
is so-called supervised training where
you say here's a picture it's a cat
here's a picture it's a dog
and you do that in typical image
identification training uh in the early
days of this I won't use like 25 million
images of a total of maybe 5 000 kinds
of objects
and so what you do is you keep on saying
oh here's this here's the picture of a
cat
um uh you know you should say it's a cat
oh you're saying it's an elephant push
in this direction
Etc et cetera saying just keep doing
that over and over again nobody knew how
hard it would be to do this there's a
big Discovery in 2011 that it was
possible to do this people didn't know
it you know it was a month of CPU time
somebody left something just running and
at the end of it it turned out it had
managed to learn a bunch of things
nobody knew that was going to work
nobody knew how hard it would be to sort
of bash the neural net to be able to
learn these things
but in any case that worked and the
thing that that happens so so there are
many many tricks in how you actually do
this training and you know for example
you might not have enough images you
could synthetically make images say well
this is a cat but we want to add to the
cat image something where we just change
the pixels around a bit and it's still a
cat and then we use that as another
piece of the training you know in some
places where people are for example
let's say training self-driving cars to
recognize different kinds of objects and
so on there's a certain amount of data
you get from just driving cars around or
having your fleet of cars from some car
manufacturer that's kind of going around
and seeing what it sees on the streets
and getting all that data back and using
that to do more training but in the end
there might not be enough training data
and in the end I think what's been done
there is people make essentially video
games for the cars to drive in
artificially
um and that's kind of the way that so
they're they're kind of driving around
millions and millions of hours of um of
sort of synthesized uh experience on
roads and and so that but but that's a
typical example of kind of this this
sort of mechanism for training where you
say this is what I want to to this is
what I'm going to feed in this is what I
want to get out now learn in the middle
of the neural Nets to do that
okay so
in the case of of chat GPT the thing we
want to do is we want to say
um here's a piece of English text it's a
big long piece of I don't know you know
you got it out of off some random web
page or it came from Shakespeare or
whatever else it was it's a piece of
English text now you say Let Me Show You
neural net the first 10 words of that
text and I want your the neural Nets to
arrange itself so that it will correctly
tell me the 11th word the 12th word Etc
et cetera Etc okay so that's that's the
task that you're training the thing on
so what you want to do is kind of bash
the neural net you want to run that
enough times with enough different
pieces of text and and sort of bash them
on that hard enough that it will
eventually learn correctly to predict
and you can say to the neural that oh
you got the wrong word there you know
let's poke you in this direction and um
uh and then
uh then you'll get a different you know
that then you'll you'll get closer to
the word you should have got based on
the training of the actual text that
you're you're shown now the the the
whole point the thing that's exciting
with something like chat GPT or with
so-called generative AI in general is
that it is often being given inputs
that's never seen before let me give the
example of a cat and dog identifier
first
so let's say you show it a very specific
photograph of a cat
then you could imagine you're going to
train it to say okay that specific
photograph of a cat it's a cat
but now let's say you modify that cat a
bit the cat has been uh you know I don't
know licking its whiskers or something
or whatever whatever the cat has its ear
in a different orientation or the cat is
on a different background or the cat is
uh you know put its pore up in some way
you still want to recognize it as a cat
and the big point about these neural
Nets and so on is that after you've
trained in enough of cat images it kind
of gets the idea of roughly what a cat
image is and so even if the cat had its
pore up it can still say oh that's a cat
okay so the the point with chat GPT is
that it's saying if there's a particular
piece of English then or text and it
could know yes that is exactly how it
should continue it's a famous you know
to be or not to be that is the question
you know whether it is noble and
whatever you know the the Shakespeare
speech right it could know exactly what
the next word is in that Shakespeare
speech but what if you gave it something
that I've never seen before it's gonna
it's gonna try and generate something
that is reasonable to generate but it's
never seen that particular input before
and the thing it's going to generate is
something that's never been seen before
as well
so I will say by the way one thing uh
that is important in chat GPT is that
sometimes it's like I've seen it before
I know exactly how to continue it
turns out that that doesn't produce very
good results so what's done in chat GPT
is it has what's called the temperature
where it knows the most likely way that
this is going to continue is blah but
actually it knows the top five ways it
might continue and instead of always
picking the most likely way to continue
it it has a little Randomness that's
sometimes picking the less likely way to
continue and so that's that's a an
important piece of the sort of the
creativity of something like chat GPT I
think it's parameters I think it's set
to 0.8
um sort of the the um the the I'm
certain I'm going to pick the top thing
will be one so it has a little bit of
uncertainty there and that's important
and if you give it no uncertainty at
least the earlier versions of things
like the the earlier
um GPT
systems if you give it no uncertainty if
you say always pick the Top Choice it
very often gets in a loop and it'll just
keep saying the same thing the same
sequence of words over and over again
the thing that's totally bizarre is that
in the end what chat GPT is doing is
it's adding one word at a time basically
even just sometimes one token one piece
of a word at a time and it's producing
this essay that seems like oh it makes
perfect sense the whole essay makes
sense but yet the way it actually worked
was just it's adding one word at a time
and that's really telling us something
about sort of the structure of of text
and and things like this well
okay how does it actually do the adding
one word at a time the uh uh okay let's
see
um the thing there is an idea that
things called Transformer Nets okay so
the the thing I was telling you about
for example an image
um when you have this image and you've
got these sort of artificial neurons and
they're connected to other artificial
neurons you're kind of flowing through
layer by layer
um typically for an image the the sort
of the neurons are the artificial
neurons are arranged in kind of an array
that corresponds to the the geometry
let's say two-dimensional geometry of
the image
um those are usually often called
convenience convolutional neural
networks that are arranged in this kind
of geometrical way actually very similar
to these cellular automata that I've
long studied
um but any case the the way that works
is
um it has these layers of neural of
artificial neurons you go from one to
the next and so on okay so there's a
slightly different idea that's used when
you're generating sequences when when
there's a as I say for for dealing with
images you you start off with your first
layers of of artificial neurons are
arranged in a grid just like the pixels
in the image actually it's very similar
to our visual cortex our primary visual
cortex at the back of our brains also
has neurons that are arranged in a way
that somehow corresponds to the way that
the cells on a retina are arranged in in
that kind of geometrical structure okay
but but so in
when you're generating a sequence
the the idea is that you'll have
something where essentially the thing
you feed into the neural net is
something that is going to be you're
trying to add to the sequence and what
you're doing is you're looking back in
the previous things that are already in
the sequence and you're taking the
things that are already in the sequence
and you're saying okay which numbered
things in that sequence should I look at
to feed into my neural Nets that works
out what the next thing should be so the
the typical thing this so-called
attention mechanism is you're you're
trying to add the next word so you're
going to look back and you're going to
say the word five ago that was important
that was a verb or something that was
important the verb the word 15 ago that
was also important that was some subject
of a sentence or something like that so
one of the things you try to do is to
learn sort of which word is worth
looking at in these in in the kind of
preceding part of the text that's kind
of the attention mechanism then what you
do is what you're basically doing is
given a set of words you're figuring out
which words are important then you're
feeding those words into something which
is very much the same kind of neural net
that I just described where you're just
saying there's this uh that there's
you're going to feed it in and then it's
going to produce okay your okay I got to
explain a couple of other things to to
make this make sense okay first point is
you are
uh what starts off as a bunch of words
the cat sat on the mat
okay what neural Nets deal with are
numbers basically uh collections of
numbers and you know is it 5.7 is it 5.8
Etc et cetera et cetera so how do you
turn the cats out on the map into a
bunch of numbers
so in a first approximation you just say
Okay V is word number one cat is word
number 714 sat is word numbers such and
such you essentially just make up
numbers for words
okay turns out that the thing that is
really useful to do is to make up not
just individual numbers for words but
for every word you have a whole
collection of numbers I think in chat
GPT it is
16 000 numbers per word I'm not sure of
that order it used to be maybe a
thousand numbers per word but it's the
the these are okay so what that is is
for every word you're saying I'm going
to characterize this word by saying it's
0.7 2.2 4.6 minus 0.8 Etc et cetera et
cetera thousands of numbers
okay what do those numbers mean well
those numbers are some kind of way of of
saying what the meaning of the word is
let me give an example
so let's say you're going to let's take
an example not with words let's say it's
with flags
flags of the world or something you want
to arrange the flags of the world on a
piece of paper so that flags that are
similar looking will be in the same
place on a piece of paper so I don't
know the um the French flag and the
Italian flag they I think they're
similar
um they you know they'll be in a similar
place the um uh the uh maybe the um
oh I'm I'm doing badly here on my Flags
but um uh you know some country that has
a big green flag is is really in a
different place from you know the US
which has a you know red white and blue
flag things like this and the you know
the the the the flag of the you know the
U.S flag might be a bit similar to the
UK flag
um I just you know how what which one is
visually similar to what so you're
trying to arrange these on a piece of
paper according to visual similarity and
so what you can then say is if you've
done that successfully actually we could
we could forget Flags we just do letters
of the alphabet so lowercase letters
they Alpha get printed like an a is
similar to a g a v is similar to a y
things like that we arrange those in
similar places on the on the page and
more from language there's a function
called feature space plot that does
exactly this that will take a bunch of
things and try and arrange them
according to their features in some ways
so that things which have similar
features are nearby Okay so so the
result of that is that you can take
anything like it's a v it's a y it's a
it's an American flag whatever it is and
you can place it somewhere in this
feature space and it'll have some
coordinates it'll be at some position
it'll be you know x coordinate this y
coordinate that
and so the point is that you try and
arrange it so that the things that are
that are that are similar in some sense
have nearby coordinates they appear
nearby in this feature space plot now in
in the real case you're doing that not
in two Dimensions but in many thousands
of Dimensions but anyway the result is
you're trying to get these things where
every word is encoded by this array of
numbers so that words that have similar
meaning are encoded with similar
collections of numbers that's usually
called an embedding word embedding it's
sort of the way that you embed words in
let's say thousand-dimensional space
um and those embeddings those learned
embeddings that you you deduce from
looking at so so the way you learn these
embeddings is to for example say uh this
word appears uh you know okay so words
like for colors for example might be
somewhat nearby in the embedding and you
can tell that because if you look at
tons of text you can substitute red for
blue in different places so there's a
sort of a framework for the sentence
where could be a red could be a blue
there we kind of know that those things
red and blue have to be somewhat similar
because they get they get arranged in
the same places in in sentences
um and so that sort of tells us
something about their similarity of
meaning you could swap crocodile for
alligator because they appear in similar
sentences and so crocodile and alligator
will be near in meaning space so that's
the way that you deduce these embeddings
these mappings from words to collections
of thousand numbers and so on those
embeddings are valuable things that's
actually something that people nowadays
sell embeddings
um because they what is it good of
having an embedding well it means that
if you've got a sentence for example and
well in the end you can do these
embeddings not just for words but for
sentences and you say I want to do a
search I want to find is there somewhere
in my documents where I have a sentence
that's like the sentence that I have now
well if you could just take every
sentence in the document and turn it
into this Vector of numbers this
collection of numbers and say are these
numbers close then that will tell you do
you have a sentence somewhere in a
document that's close to the one that
you're looking for
okay so there are a bunch of tricks in
in the case of chat GPT
um there are a bunch of tricks that are
used so for example you can say well the
words come in a sequence
um uh you know
um the cat sat on the mat uh it's kind
of inconvenient to have those words be
actually arranged the cat sat on the mat
rather there's a positional encoding so
that you basically include with the V
you include in that big Vector you
include information that says oh that
was the first word the next one that was
the second word it's kind of a weird
little positional tag that gets included
so that allows you to take all those
words and basically put them in a big
vat they're just a bunch of words bunch
of vectors that correspond to these
words just put them in this vat then
you use this attention mechanism to
decide which of these words you are
going to sort of arrange in what order
and how much weight you're going to put
on each one then you feed that into this
neural net then you get out the sort of
prediction for the next word now okay of
course it's actually more complicated
than this there are like the typical
thing that's happening is for every word
you're going through many iterations of
this attention feed forward it's called
feed forward when you when you have this
um this thing which just sort of feeds
through a neural network you're doing I
think it's 16 layers maybe maybe it's
more than that in chat GPT
um some number of tens of iterations of
that process now that's what what
happens when you're trying to when
you're running chat GPT and it's trying
to figure out the next word when you're
training it you have to do sort of the
whole thing kind of in reverse and you
have to kind of feed it you have to say
well what do you think you know GPT what
do you think the next word is oh no no
you're wrong let's tell you a different
word instead
okay so that that's that's the main part
of the training is that
there's an additional part of the
training which is tricky and which is
actually one of the things that really I
think has has separated chat GPT from
the previous generations of so-called
large language models things which are
sort of models of of how text is
generated
um the uh but let me uh well okay so so
the the first step is sort of the the
main training of the thing so I think in
chat GPT it's it's um using an
underlying language model that has about
175 billion parameters so over the
course of you know CPU years GPU years
more more to the point
um you are sort of gradually refining
those 175 billion parameters to
represent the statistical
characteristics of all of those billions
of pages on the web and millions of of
books and all this kind of thing those
175 billion parameters encode the kind
of the information of what is typical
text like that you see out there on the
web and so on now that's to be compared
and our brains maybe we have a few
trillion synapses between our neurons so
the number of parameters in in chat GPT
is not that different from the number in
a brain although it knows about a lot of
stuff that is much more obscure than
even people like me know about
um you know who have decent human
memories
um I think the the and there are a lot
of tricky issues about um you know is it
really does it really need uh precise
numbers 0.2785644
et cetera et cetera et cetera that
really doesn't matter
um I think I don't know how many chat
apt is using but it's probably just
using about 255 levels
um for each number rather than having a
precise number that can be any number of
digits
Okay so
uh that that's the basic thing is
there's this whole attention mechanism
and you're you're you know it's trying
to continue the text okay it's another
important piece which is so-called
reinforcement training reinforcement
learning applied to chat gbt so people
ran these chat Bots and it's like well
what's the chatbot going to produce well
sometimes a chatbot produces crazy stuff
it's off yakking about you know just
gone completely Bonkers it's it's uh
it's it's off the deep end in some way
um and so what was done was that people
were told you know have a chat with this
chat bot and rate it tell it well you're
off the deep end is it going in the
wrong direction oh no no that's great
that's bad that's great Etc et cetera et
cetera so groups of people actually did
this and turns out that's a very
powerful it turns out it's again not so
obvious that that's a powerful thing for
directing what the output will really
look like I think there's probably also
a certain amount of templating that's
been done for particular kinds of you
know make a poem make a make an essay
things like that that's sort of just
engineering on top of on top of other
things just to make a a better user
experience for the system but the thing
that that is sort of important is that
you have these groups of people and
they're like telling it do this do that
and that's then fed into this
um uh
uh that that's that's fed into the kind
of training of the neural net there's a
there's an additional layer that is this
reinforcement training that kind of
keeps it more or less on track that
seems to be important people can
obviously can obviously be very
controversial to say well you know
you've had some group of people that are
training it that are really keen on you
know I don't know what the the critical
character of uh you know why
I don't know that are really keen on on
this feature of the world or that
feature of the world or or their they're
really big on promoting the you know the
rights of cats over dogs or whatever
else it is and so that set of people
that did that final training independent
of of just feeding in the big pile of
stuff from the web the people who did
the final training have a lot more
control over it's gonna like cats not
dogs
um and so that's sort of an issue and
there's there's kind of a bunch of
questions about how that should be done
and what this new generation of kind of
AI Wranglers
um you know how one sort of gets the
right groups of people and how one sort
of stops things in in the right way
there but that's a that's sort of a
different issue but but that's the
that's the basic idea so I think I I
think I more or less went through kind
of how how chat GPT works and what it's
always doing is it's generating a word
at a time sometimes it's sub word and
you can see that it makes up words
because it has tokens that are not quite
a whole word and so it can end up gluing
together those two tokens to make up a
word that's never been seen before and
so
it is uh
uh yeah so so it's doing this everything
it's doing it's taking the prompt the
original prompt it's saying what's the
next token what's the next word it's
giving you that it's taking the prompt
plus the token feeding that back as as
another thing and saying okay now
continue that and it keeps doing that
over and over again until you get your
complete object out and I think as I say
it can it can go about 2048 steps doing
that that that's the distance back that
it's kind of a tension system looks
um to make to keep coherence in the text
so you know if it was talking at Blue
Wolves At the beginning if you ask it to
go too long it'll be talking about uh
you know orange you know Elephants or
something at the end and it will have
completely lost the thread of what it
was talking about because it only has
sort of a finite look back
um that's that's how far the training
could be it could be made to work
um
that's uh
okay well anyway so that was a basic
explanation